- Hi guys.
- How's it going?
- Hey.
- Oh my gosh, okay.
Liz, hi, how are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
- I'm really great.
I love your album so much and I can't wait
for Christmas to come
because I wanna decorate
the Christmas tree with my
daughters and put on the album.
And it feels obviously perennial,
but it just has this classic,
wonderful, holiday, old world era music.
And Seth, you've always been that guy.
In fact, Seth and I, fun fact everyone,
used to have lots of cocktails
and go karaokeing with groups of friends.
And I miss those days so much, Seth.
- Yeah, it's, I miss it too.
You know, that was fun.
We used to go to this spot
called the Brass Monkey
in Los Angeles every Monday night,
after work at "Family Guy".
And that's actually where I met Liz.
- Well, you know, I wouldn't be surprised
if you two were from another era,
because when I listen
to your beautiful album,
"Songs From Home".
How did this come about?
And where were you guys
when you recorded it?
- Liz, the whole thing
was actually Liz's idea.
- Was it?
- This, she's, you know, we're all,
we're stuck in this quarantine.
We're not doing anything with
our little silly abilities.
And so, why don't we make some music?
And, we have, it's a
very interesting setup
where each musician,
oftentimes 50 or 60 of them,
are all recording in their homes.
We have a very talented engineer,
Rich Breen, who mixes all
of these tracks together.
And it makes it sound like the
orchestra that it in fact is.
And then she records in
Atlanta and I record in LA.
- Well, Seth, I think you know
the most talented musicians in the world.
And I think that they play a huge part.
And then, I guess, having
setups on either coast, sort of,
not that I'm technically
on a coast, really helped.
And Seth would record first and
then I would record my part.
And then we kinda just took it from there.
And it worked out, thank God,
because it was a lot of fun.
It made quarantine a
lot less dull, for sure.
- So Liz, you would
take your peanut butter,
and Seth would take his chocolate,
and then you would put it together
and make musical Reese's Pieces.
- Beautiful jazz sandwich, yes.
- Seth, you've always been
a fan of this era of music.
Did you think that this is
just another perfect time
to put out this old world classic music?
- Yeah.
I mean, again, Liz and I used to
sing with symphony orchestras.
I would go, I would travel
around with Joel McNeely,
who's my conductor, and Liz
would come and sing some duets.
With the Chicago symphony,
with the Philadelphia symphony,
the San Francisco symphony.
So we've been doing this
actually for a while,
for a long time actually.
And we hadn't ever
actually recorded anything
except one song about Buicks.
(everyone laughs)
- I love a good Buick.
- Don't we all?
And you know, my fans, they're a bit of a
different demographic
than Seth's fan base.
And that's what was really cool too,
to bring those two together.
And this was new for
them, this style of music,
they hadn't listened to it that much.
So to introduce them, and
see how much they love it,
and now how much they look
forward to it was really awesome.
- It's also rad to hear like crooner music
being said it's gonna drop every week.
You sort of mix the peanut
butter and the chocolate
of the old world and the new world.
Before we go, Seth, I just have to say,
hi from Jillian, how's Brian?
- Oh, yes, that's right, that's right.
From "Family Guy".
Yes, that's right.
- I mean, I had so many, so many fun years
of coming into the studio
on Wilshire Boulevard
and recording in the booth with you.
I was always doing fun things.
And then you told me, all right,
now you're gonna play Jillian,
who's Brian's girlfriend.
And she's sort of an airhead.
And she talks like this.
And I have to say, it's sadly
not that far off from my own voice.
And I miss Brian and
Jillian, Seth, I really do.
By the way, Seth, how's
the cousin thing going?
- Yes, that's right.
Yes, yeah.
Drew and I are distant cousins,
we discovered years ago.
- How crazy is that?
- Wow.
- It's somewhere, the
Barrymores and the MacFarlanes,
there's, this was like years ago,
my dad did our family tree.
And he was like, oh, oh
my god, look at this.
It's distant, it's like
a fourth or fifth cousin,
I think that's the relation.
But it's there.
- You know what's so funny?
I think he discovered them drinking
and doing karaoke all those years ago.
And that's why we had
to bring it full circle
and keep it alive.
- That's right.
Karaoke's been around since the Mayflower.
- Well, I know that I've always had fun
hanging out with you, Seth.
And Liz, everyone at our
company loves you so much.
We had the privilege of
working with you years ago.
And we all celebrate you guys.
And we're so excited to
talk about this album.
It's a beautiful soundtrack
for our lives right now.
So thank you for putting
another wonderful thing
out there into the world, you guys.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Thanks, Drew.
- Thank you guys so much
for coming on the show.
Liz Gillies and Seth MacFarlane.
Their new collection of songs,
"Songs From Home", now
available on Spotify.
They're all out.
And Seth has a new album as well,
"Great Songs From the Stage and Screen".
And that's available right now too.
Guess what I will be listening to
throughout the rest of the year as well.
Thank you, Seth.
(upbeat music)